se faire cambrioler une mésaventure que
plusieurs personnalités ont déjà vécu
c'est quand même un vrai traumatisme et
tout ça c'est très violent et ceux qui
en ont récemment fait les frais après
Aya Nakamura en décembre dernier ce sont
Rachel le grain trap anime Miss France
2016 et son compagnon Valentin Léonard
le 18 janvier ça fout les boules de
savoir que des personnes qui se rentrer
chez vous sans aucune infinité et se
servir tranquillement un cambriolage
traumatisant et qui a été suivi d'un
deuxième survenu moins d'un mois après
tandis que Valentin était parti assister
au match PSG - Bayern et que Rachel
était en soirée les deux amoureux ont
constaté à leur retour que ce deuxième
cambriolage était encore plus violent
que le premier carrément ils ont foncé
dans les barrières avec une voiture
alors cambriolage à répétition chez les
stars doivent-elles se montrer plus
discrète
alors la question c'est vrai qu'elle est
là est-ce que les stars doivent se
montrer plus discrètes Gilles Verdez
s'il te plaît moi j'ai été cambriolée
ils ont volé quoi
[Rires]
c'est c'est pour j'ai été cambriolé
pendant que j'étais à l'émission non
c'est pas vrai je vous le dis ouais
ouais mais quel rapport avec les stars
[Rires]
il y a déjà un moment et
les connaissances
la police scientifique est venue et se
demander si c'était lié si j'avais été
suivi et pourquoi il se demandait ça
parce que ils avaient eu l'exemple d'une
journaliste star qui avait été suivi ses
portes un bijou à l'antenne qui a été
qui a été suivi jusque chez elle et
ensuite ils ont repéré ils ont revu
qu'elle était à l'antenne en direct ils
sont venus cambrioler chez elle ils sont
persuadés ils peuvent repérer tous les
bijoux et alors tout même les bijoux de
famille en tout cas ils sont persuadés
que des gens qui sont à la télévision
star ou pas star mais son suivi pour
qu'on les cambriole après
parce que je trouve
sortir oui je voulais dire quelque chose
peut-être que les gens ne savent pas
quand un milliardaire achète un diamant
ah je sais pas combien de carats mettons
à 10 millions de dollars on leur fournit
un faux qui est destiné être porté c'est
tout le temps et dans un coffre à la
banque exactement
un cambriolage c'est moins d'une minute
en moyenne ce que c'est souvent des gens
qui sont pas hyper équipés et c'est il
reste il fouille ils prennent à hauteur
donc en général il faut il faut laisser
traîner une fausse Rolex que tu as payé
50 euros un faux trucs dès qu'il trouve
quelque chose ils s'en vont ils ont pas
le temps de chercher donc c'est vrai
qu'il faut laisser des leurs comme ça
maintenant moi j'ai je lance un autre
débat
qui va énerver beaucoup de gens
l'animateur
[Rires]
je suis à fond pour que Paris soit
entièrement sous caméra toutes les
prises partout et en permanence je suis
désolé ça va moi je suis d'accord avec
toi
mais moi je suis complètement dans
l'hiver
il est insupportable mais je l'adore
dans la vie mais il est insu est-ce que
tu es pour moi je suis d'accord avec lui
mais partout dans toutes les rues dans
toutes les rues même si dans toutes les
rues dans toutes les villes voilà et je
vous le dis ça c'est une mesure qu'il
faut prendre très vite et je pense que
Gérald Darmanin et pour en plus
impossible de quadriller la France
entière et les caméras pour Monaco déjà
c'est contre toi mais les grandes villes
sur le principe qui est de la vidéo
surveillance partout pour suivre les
gens espionner les gens etc parce que ça
va occasionner ce qu'on a vu dans des
commerces ou les commerçants après
diffuse il va y avoir de la diffusion il
va y avoir la diffusion d'image
qu'est-ce que tu
absolument pas il va y avoir la
diffusion d'image qui vont être piratés
à travers des appartements c'est un bon
comportement
c'est lui c'est le monde des il vous
protégera toujours ouais
c'est ça absolument après il vient se
plaindre absolument pas travailler
qu'une arme il faut faire tout ça et
vous serez tranquille
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai et vous serez tranquille dans
le monde de gilbertez
regarde à quoi il pense qu'il pense au
mec donc il m'a volé un an après il va
voir sa vidéo non franchement
j'étais pas rasé sur là non mais j'avais
là tout ouf il y a que deux cellules la
prison c'est que deux cellules et elles
sont vides
elles sont vides alors on va la
prochaine fois que je vais à Monaco
comme ça coûte hyper cher peut-être je
vais me faire arrêter j'ai rangé lui
comme ça moi ça marche pas parce que
même les cellules à Monaco va être belle
non mais c'est Monaco votre exemple de
nomade Monaco c'est extraordinaire en
terme de Monaco il y a pas un mètre
carré qui est pas filmé bien sûr
c'est un cul-de-sac en plus quelque
chose tu ressors jamais votre exemple de
démocratie
j'en ai rien contre Monaco je n'ai rien
contre Monaco je dis contre Monaco mais
rien
[Applaudissements]
je t'adore et tu sais comme je t'aime
dans la vie mais je ne sais même pas
comment tu peux Géraldine par exemple
comme Levallois
les administrés adorent les animaux en
fait
on l'embrasser donc franchement je
comprends pas Gilles en fait non mais en
fait tu penses que je vais libérer
ici en fait c'est de ne pas être en
sécurité c'est ça la vraie tu vois le
vrai manque de liberté pour tout le
monde en fait vous vivez dans un monde
où on va nous surveiller en permanence
chez toi tu vis dans un monde tu veux te
dire tu vis dans le monde là je vais te
dire toi tu sais tant que dans quel
monde tu lis tu vis dans le monde dans
lequel on est actuellement le monde qui
va dans le mur donc je vais te dire et
toi tu es dans la voiture et tu vas tout
droit dans le mur et personne ne dit
rien en toi est accélère toi
et pourquoi pas ça pourquoi pas ça
pourquoi décrocher de ta fille merci
mon avis qui soit dans la rue arrête de
faire genre
un ami un ami si tu veux on s'en fout
hein
alors quelqu'un de très proche que tu es
dans ta famille tu as pas envie que
c'est une fille par exemple qui a 12 ou
14 ans elle puisse se promener à minuit
qu'elle soit parfaitement en sécurité tu
as pas envie de ça mais qu'est-ce que
vous racontez vous pensez que des
caméras vont changer le monde
mais pourquoi les gens roulent sur
l'autoroute c'est pas pour se sauver de
la police
tu crois que les mecs tu crois que les
mecs c'est parce qu'ils ont peur qu'il
roule pas de caméra
d'agressions distributeur de billets il
y a une caméra au dessus des tous les
distributeurs délinquance sera toujours
plus fort que les systèmes ce qu'il faut
c'est empêcher la balance
tu veux que je te dise des courses
on va l'assemblée avec les insoumis
c'est comme ça que ça va finir Gilles
c'est comme ça que tu vas finir tu vas
finir comme ça
[Applaudissements]
la vidéo surveillance est-ce que toi ça
te pose un problème tu dis ah non je
veux pas excuse-moi ça fait accélérer
l'enquête alors donc
c'est quoi ta logique en fait pourquoi
quand la vidéo surveillance a permis de
faire avancer l'enquête pourquoi tu dis
c'est bien et on en parle et pourquoi tu
veux pas te généraliser le globaliser en
fait d'abord je réponds à Cyril vous me
dites va chez les insoumis parce que ce
que vous sous-entendez subordonné ces
quêtes de gauche et être pro délinquance
antisé etc
moi je suis de gauche et je suis pour
une sécurité maximale j'avais même pas
que les insoumis étaient de gauche tu
vois alors d'accord pour moi c'est juste
des bordel ils sont pas bons moi je fous
pas le bordel vous remet ne sont pas
beaucoup
été remèdes tes remède c'est de la merde
tes remède c'est ce qu'on fait déjà tu
vois bien que ça marche pas c'est des de
la France insoumise de tes potes là qui
disent que des conneries bien sûr que la
police tue toi aussi
nous assimilez pas à ça
je désormais pas la police d'accord
j'ai dit qu'il y avait des brebis
gazeuses dans la police comme ça
mais j'ai jamais dit que la posture que
la police faisait pas son boulot moi
quand j'ai un souci j'appelle la police
j'en ai en ce moment ils sont toujours
là pour m'épauler et cetera donc je
dirais jamais du mal de la police en
tant qu'institution ça c'est clair
Gilles pourquoi les policiers réclament
tous la vidéo surveillance globaliser
généralisée sur le territoire
[Applaudissements]
j'avais une passion quand j'étais plus
jeune c'était des montres j'ai
économiser voilà je
plus personne ici de porte de montre le
sexe si tu portes du Londres en 24
heures on t'a coupé la main ou tu as
dépouillé dans Paris c'est normal ça
mais si jamais
tu as des motards devant toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas la même hein
j'en ai une qu'on avait au moins 120
ce que je dis j'adorais mon frère ce
beau cadeau ça sera de mes rêves une
jolie montre et alors je peux pas j'ai
peur à cause de toi
et quand les arrête tu veux pas les
mettre en tôle parce que c'est le pire
quand il sort
[Rires]
délinquants en prison parce qu'il trouve
que c'est pire la prison quand ils
sortent après ça c'est vrai Jean-Michel
de toi
tu refuses qu'on mette les prix les
délinquants en prison tu trouves que
c'est pire la prison que quand ils sont
libertés
en prison quand il ressort plus
délinquant des mineurs parler des
mineurs donc
le système ne marche pas c'est le monde
proposition Gilles mais toi est-ce que
tu proposes c'est l'ancien système tu
vas bien que ça a pas marché non c'est
d'empêcher qu'il y ait des délinquants
c'est d'empêcher la délinquance
tu as raison tu claques dans tes doigts
et puis c'est Joseph
je lui demande comment on éteint
[Applaudissements]
tu n'as jamais de solution c'est ton
problème tu dénonces des trucs et tu
n'as jamais arrivé
les caméras vidéos ça ne marche pas
quadrillé la France par des caméras
vidéo vous avez des grandes villes sur
argent alors ça c'est pire
alors là c'est dégueulasse qui dit parce
que il dit les grandes villes et ça
c'est le mépris de la France
[Applaudissements]
il y a des statistiques tu vois les
villes où il y a le plus de délinquants
c'est tu mets les caméras c'est bête ou
quoi
[Musique]
délinquance en milieu ruraux
quelqu'un qui est à côté oui délinquance
en milieu rural explose et vous les
méprisez en disant les villes on va les
laisser tomber pas du tout
moi je peux plus
tu sais très bien que c'est le mec qui à
côté tout le monde se connaît
non mais c'est rien mais tu es con mais
c'est faux ce que vous dites tout mon
respect il y a des banques qui viennent
écumer le milieu rural en France en ce
moment alors maintenant les caméras non
mettons les caméras mais on ne peut pas
en mettre partout vous êtes cons ou quoi
au bout d'un moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non il y a 5 boules qui parlent partout
dans tous les feux rouges ou pas
il y en a plein dans Paris à quoi elle
sert les boules uniquement pour Quand tu
es dans la boîte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]